- Do you understand who's next?
Do you understand what
it means to be next?
- [Group] Yay!
- [Gary] You got your perspective.
(crowd cheers)
I just wanna be happy,
don't you wanna be happy?
(soft electric music)
- Gotta do a ton of podcasts.
- As a guest.
- But doing the effort of then
going into creating your own
you still think it's a viable channel
even with all the noise out there?
- I do.
- Really?
'Cause I do think it's a game of best
versus a game of first.
You know, like, I think your
take on a healthy economy
from a franchising
thing is very important.
'Cause it leads to
people saving more money.
Like, there's a lot of
good that comes from
You know, one of the reasons
I wanted to take this meeting
and like, I think it's very important
in the history of
entrepreneurship in America
for more actual entrepreneurs to get more
of the percentage of the voice.
Because there's a lot of misinformation
and a lot of the fakeness
that comes along with this right now.
- Yeah, and that's why--
- How long did you have the first truck?
- First truck for three years.
- I need that story brother.
- I dropped out of school--
- Brother, I need that story.
- Yeah.
- Like anybody watching this right now
or listening or whatever
thing they're gonna do
with the content or are new to this
and they hear 370 million, 30-year,
but three years, you
had one fucking truck.
- I didn't franchise 'til 10 years in.
It took me eight years to get
to a million a year revenue.
We do a million on a given day now.
But that's the slow and steady
and everyone in this Instagram
world wants right away, yeah.
- And they always did.
- Yeah.
Everyone's blaming social media.
Guess what, we're old enough
to know they always did.
That's why they watched
infomercials at night.
That's why they fuckin', they always did.
- They're not getting enough--
- Patience,
or when they do they're so flabbergasted
why they've worked so hard for nine days
and nothing's happened yet.
Eight years to a million.
- Eight years!
- Love it.
By the way, that's what this is.
You know, like, this is one big version
of that for me too.
You know, like, same thing
with like Wine Library.
Like it, you know, like it
took years to build something.
Like, this is just a foundation
building for my next thing.
(upbeat music)
- You tryin' to get followers?
- Yeah.
- There's only one way.
If I do a normal post, and I
tell everybody to follow you.
- Oh, I see.
- Got it?
(laughter)
- There's no, otherwise
you get 12, 49, 103 --
- It's not true, I used to get a lot.
- When I'd say, you know, when
I'd tell them to follow you.
- Really?
- Yeah.
- Otherwise, they don't do--
- Otherwise you'll get seven, 12, 50, 100.
Can you keep my dad entertained
so I can bang through
these employees real quick?
- [Man] Yeah.
- Make a piece of, help
him make a piece of content
that will go viral.
You have to, you guys have
to teach him right now.
Create a fake account.
Create a secondary account
on his phone right now.
- [Man] Yeah.
- And like, literally spend the,
you've got time?
Literally spend, and you
got a bunch of you, like,
figure out, like, I know,
- [Man] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- But you're busy, like let's figure out,
or it can be you, I don't give a shit.
He has to practice, like,
he has to post 30 times in a row.
On a fake account, create it right now.
Put it as secondary, switch
it over on his phone.
- [Man] And post it in his stories, yup.
- Make him do everything.
Show him how to
And repetitive, repetitive,
repetitive, repetitive
for two hours and then he'll get it.
(camera clicks)
- How are you guys?
Good to see you.
- Hello, good to see you, Brandon Perkins.
- It's a pleasure, Brandon.
- Hi.
- [Abby] Hi, I'm Abby.
- Abby, how are you?
- [Abby] Nice to meet you.
- Todd Connors.
- Hey Todd, I'm ready to get to work.
(laughing)
Chez, can you get somebody
to help us so we don't waste
so we can, so I can talk to 'em.
You want me to sign the
same ones as Barney?
- Absolutely.
- You sign Kansas City along here
- You know, I like
You know, it's funny
you picked up on that.
I'm a fan of Kansas City.
I just like it.
I like the city a lot.
Plus I like the Chiefs
in a weird way, I hate --
- I have to say, that
doesn't sound anything like
- Well, no, I mean, I hate the Chiefs.
(laughing)
But like, because I hate
everybody but the Jets.
But I have empathy for Chief fans
because they're basically
the same as the Jets.
- You're looking forward to buying them?
That way you can win?
- So much my friend.
So much mainly because
I think if I completely,
if I can pull it off,
boy, will it become something
that a lot of people
long after I'm dead
can use as a framework.
Because it's not just that I pull it off.
It's that, I'm gonna become
one of the first people ever
to fully document the 30 years of patience
and hard work it took
and miss the period of my journey.
But like, you know, I'm
gonna buy them in 25 years.
That's a lot of content, you know?
- [Brandon] For somebody
to go through and learn --
- It's just gonna educate people,
like, you know, you
hear about things like,
she was a little girl, and
now she did this company,
But you're missing the 41
years that she broke her back.
- [Todd] Right.
- I'm documenting it.
- [Brandon] Yes, you are.
- So, yeah.
- [Brandon] For your grandkids, grandkids.
- You know, it's funny we
had a really weird moment
at the Super Bowl this weekend,
me, AJ and DRock and Tyler watched
some episodes of DailyVee
from three years ago.
It was really fascinating.
Oh my God!
Go back!
(TV plays)
Oh my God, this is incredible, ready?
- Is it the Super Bowl?
- Nope.
- This is Super Bowl --
- Go back to the, look
at this, look at the cab.
- PureWow?
- [Man] Purewow! Wow!
That was before the acquisition.
- Already, and that's only three years.
Like, AJ hates my content,
cause he's my brother,
and he's like, I don't, he
doesn't watch any of it.
- [Brandon] He doesn't
wanna watch your face?
- He doesn't need it, he lived it.
But he's like, man, this is entertaining.
(drumbeat music)
And also, what's the strategy of like,
I really wanna make sure that if you film,
then Dustin can film today.
Because then you could be working on post.
I really think nobody should
film back-to-back days.
Nobody should film back-to-back days.
Got it?
It's just I want it fast.
I want it fast.
It's gonna work.
All right, there they are.
- [Man] What's up?
- What's up guys?
[Man] Can you hear us?
- 100%.
- Before we get into a question or two
I wanna give you guys the opportunity,
I thank you so much for
supporting the K-Swiss'
and I wanna make sure
you guys get a chance
to promote your guys event
which I know you guys have
worked real hard to get.
Like, the amount of hustle
that you guys have used
to try to get me there, I appreciate.
I also, I'm really proud of myself.
You're not gonna wanna hear this
but three or four years ago
when somebody tried as
hard as you guys did
even though it wasn't the
right amount of dollars
and I had things going on, I
would always bend and break
because I respected it so much.
So, I'm glad I've been able to say no
consistently to you guys.
Because that's something
I actually had to work on.
But nonetheless, tell everybody
a little bit about your event.
- Yeah, so we put together a
little recap of what we did
to get you to our event.
(laughs)
And we just wanted to
show you that and then
- I love it, I'm ready.
- Okay, all right.
This is how you get Gary
Vee to speak at your event.
Gary charges 250K plus first class travel
for one keynote speech.
- Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Makin' money.
- But we are broke, so we
have to find another way.
- [Lucas] Step one, get 2000 people
really hyped about the idea.
- So Gary, are you ready, because,
- [Crowd] We're ready!
We're ready!
(Gary laughing)
- [Robby] Dock his Insta Stories
to figure out when and where
he will arrive at the airport.
- That's smart.
- Hey, I'm Robby.
- How are you?
- [Lucas] Nice to meet you, Lucas.
- Oh yeah.
- [Robby] Give him some presents.
And then pitch him.
- [Lucas] We're from Germany.
We came all the way here today.
We have an event this year
with 2 1/2 thousand people,
two days 5000 people,
Mike Tyson as a headline speaker.
- That's awesome.
When is it?
- [Lucas] 27 and 28th of April.
- I will absolutely try.
I'm interested in coming
to that particular event.
You catch me at a good time
because now Zack left CA,
we're starting Vayner
Speakers, we wanna build it up.
So, I'm gonna speak more next year.
But I'm gonna wanna do is
say, I'll take less money.
If I'm 250 and you offer 150, I'll say,
give me 100, give 50 to these two people,
cause they now work with Vayner Speakers.
So I'm gonna be motivated
next year to speak,
we'll be in touch.
- I promise, you would
never forget our event.
- I believe you, I can feel the energy.
- [Lucas] Step three, order 35 pairs
of Gary's Clouds & Dirt sneakers
to get a five-minute
Instagram live with him.
Contact Barney, the CEO of
K-Swiss to discuss ideas
on how to get Gary to your event.
Oh, and by the way,
- I also offered to name my son Gary.
- That's interesting.
- I even promised to tattoo
Gary's signature on my arm.
(Gary laughing)
- [Robby] Step four, fly to New York City
to drop off some of your hottest merch
at the offices of Vayner Media.
Hey DRock, thanks for the Instagram Story.
Step five, get Jeff Nicholson
the CMO of Vayner Media
on your podcast and ask him for advice.
- [Lucas] How could we pitch
Gary as a speaker for our event
and how can you help us to do so?
- [Jeff] I will publicly
tag him with you on a post
in the near future to see
if I can get his attention
so at least I get you some awareness.
- To seal the deal, get
a loan from the bank
and offer him 100K for one keynote speech
or 10K for a video conference.
That will surely get him.
- [Man] Thinking back, it's
either 100 live on a Sunday
But then the opposite is
10,000 for a video conference
so like we do the recording on a Sunday.
Pass.
When is the event?
- [Man] They said about April 25th, 26th?
- Are we already fill up?
- 27 and 28th of April.
Yeah, the bit, guys what
this video didn't show
is the biggest mistake you made,
which is you scheduled your conference
during the NFL Draft, which
is the most important time
for me and AJ at Vayner Sports.
Like honestly, and I think you could tell
through my eyes, like, I wanted to like,
kind of reward you right now.
You fucked up on the NFL Draft.
But you didn't know that.
That's a big problem.
I think look, here's what I would say.
If you guys work with
me on dates for 2020,
for sure, I feel very
confident that we can get,
I'm coming.
We can get something done.
But I don't wanna promise right now
when I don't know how we're gonna do it.
We can have one more convo about it.
(drumbeat music)
- What's up?
- You did a great job out there with them.
- Thank you.
- You know what's crazy, though?
It's just the beginning.
You're so young.
- I'm only 20, man.
- This is where people get
fucked up a little bit, right?
Like, I was talking to
somebody the other day,
I was like, their album didn't
go as well as they wanted to.
And I'm like, and?
- Keep going.
Ain't nothing to worry, dawg.
- I was like, drop a fucking
mixed tape next week.
and one song can change you life.
So, get gassed for it.
- Yes.
- But like
- Brace yourself.
- Like honestly, don't
get too high or too low.
It's gonna be what it's gonna be.
You could have a song in there
that changes your life forever.
Or it just might be solid cause
I know it's gonna be good.
- It's not gonna be like, oh
I already know, just
cause I've listened to it
and I'd be like, it's not
gonna be like you're finished.
It's just like people don't understand
how building blocks work.
(plays song)
Yeah, I was right there.
We have so much footage together.
We got the footage when he did it.
♪ Yeah, I called Gary Vee ♪
♪ Now your gon' give me that fresh body ♪
♪ Whoo ♪
- We were in the studio.
We got the party.
Do you understand who's next?
Do you understand what
it means to be next?
Right here.
- Yeah, what's up?
Shleck.
(drumbeat music)
- [Radio presenter] And you've been able
to with your own personal brand
supplement your personal income that way?
- Correct.
- [Radio presenter] As well,
it was like a huge strategy.
- Correct, a huge thing for me
which I think is super unique
and I don't think is a
practical advice for everybody
but like, Jesus, if
you can make your money
in a way that allows you to be better
to your audience and to your
employees, you've got leverage.
And that's what I have.
So, I think getting a sense of like,
what are you actually up to
is super important.
And if you're like, I love what I do,
well then you should invest
in that beast forever.
If you're like, I just want some money
and buy a home in Jamaica and live there,
well then maximize it and squeeze it.
I think it's a very important thing.
I just don't think most people
know what they're doing.
When I say, know what they
are doing, I mean macro.
Like, why do you have this business?
- [Radio presenter] Correct.
And it doesn't need to
be as super complicated,
and back to your point --
- Is this a lifestyle business?
- [Radio presenter] It's legacy or what?
- Is this a legacy?
Is this, you wanna make
as much money as possible,
flip it and do something else?
Like, if you are honest with yourself
and everybody around you
employees will work for you
if you tell them that you're gonna drive
everybody into the ground and flip it.
Because some of them may say,
well I just need the fucking paycheck.
Or they may say, oh cool,
I wanna be in flipped.
Or cool, I just wanna watch her do it
and then maybe I'll do it.
Like, truth really is good.
It's really really good.
(drumbeat music)